Trascrizione: Chiara Imbesi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Salve a tutti, sono Anna.
Sono un'antropologa:
e ogni estate, da dieci anni circa,
mi trasferisco a vivere in un paese,
uno dei tanti paesi d'Italia
che probabilmente,
tra qualche anno, non esisterà più.
Faccio parte di una missione
di archeologi e di antropologi
chiamati ad implementare
la carta archeologica
del territorio in Abruzzo,
che vuol dire aggiornarla.
Ma il primo giorno di campo,
successe qualcosa di inedito.
Il professore mi disse:
"Anna, da quest'anno ti occuperai
della parte antropologica",
dato che fino a quel momento avevo scavato
con i miei colleghi archeologi.
Così cominciai a studiare
il paese che ci ospitava:
Frattura, in Abruzzo.
Frattura è un piccolo paese
di soli 20 abitanti
sito a 1350 mt di altitudine,
completamente isolato.
Ha una caratteristica:
ha due insediamenti.
Uno completamente diruto, terremotato,
dal terribile terremoto della Marsica
che nel 1915 fece 30.000 morti
in Abruzzo in 30 secondi;
e un nuovo insediamento,
costruito nel 1940,
che era quello che ci ospitava.
Così cominciai e partii da lì
per le mie ricerche.
Frattura ha una cultura orale,
e mi resi conto che la maggior parte
delle informazioni che cercavo
si trovavano ancora sotto le macerie.
Mi resi anche conto che in Italia,
di paesi come Frattura ne esistono
centinaia, se non migliaia,
destinati a scomparire
e a non lasciare traccia.
Mi resi conto che stavo assistendo
a un mondo in estinzione,
e tutto ciò mi appassionò.
In Italia, le aree interne corrispondono
a circa il 30% del territorio nazionale,
in cui vivono 13 milioni di abitanti,
in cui i diritti e i servizi
essenziali non sono garantiti,
o sono stati smantellati,
o si trovano a circa un'ora di distanza.
Stiamo parlando di scuole, presidi medici,
ospedali, negozi, biblioteche;
ma anche di uffici postali e banche.
E il digital divide
rende le comunicazioni difficili.
Quando iniziai ad occuparmi
di questo argomento,
ero una delle poche in Italia
che se ne occupava:
e mi resi conto che non
esisteva documentazione,
e che l'università
aveva trascurato questo argomento.
Negli ultimi anni abbiamo assistito
a un grande "trend topic",
un grande "hype" legato ai borghi e paesi:
vuol dire che se ne è parlato tanto,
perché hanno destato un grande interesse.
Ma nonostante se ne sia parlato tanto,
tuttora non sappiamo quali siano
le effettive condizioni
delle persone che abitano questi luoghi.
Durante la pandemia,
abbiamo assistito al fenomeno
del "turismo di prossimità",
che vuol dire visitare luoghi vicino casa.
Complice anche il marketing territoriale,
che rimanda ad un'idea luminosa
di questi territori
chiamandoli "regine del turismo,
o avamposti di innovazione.
Complice anche il fatto
che quando parliamo di paesi, e di borghi,
è come se fossimo sequestrati dal passato;
da un passato nostalgico,
di una vita in paese
che non abbiamo mai vissuto
e che abbiamo solamente ascoltato
nei racconti dei nostri genitori
e dei nostri nonni.
Ma nonostante se ne parli tanto,
la vita delle persone non è cambiata;
e la narrazione di questi luoghi
non è realistica.
Durante le mie ricerche
in giro per l'Italia,
mi è capitato di visitare anche
uno dei borghi più belli,
quelli che vediamo in TV
la domenica mattina.
Così, decisi di entrare
in una delle tante chiese:
per scoprire che la mafia
locale, la `ndrangheta,
aveva completamente derubato, spogliato,
tutti gli arredamenti interni,
trasformando la chiesa
in un grande stanzone bianco.
Per riabitare questi territori,
abbiamo bisogno di cura
e ricerche situate;
ma soprattutto, di raccontare tutto
e non omettere nulla.
E dare la voce ai paesani,
perché sono loro i primi sociologi.
Solo così scopriremo
che vivere nei paesi non è semplice,
e che ogni anno centinaia,
se non migliaia di ragazzi e ragazze
preferisco andarsene,
determinando quello che è il grande esodo
del sud e delle aree interne.
Perché la garanzia per rimanere
a vivere in questi paesi
è la garanzia del reddito:
di produrlo e di mantenerlo.
Mentre chi cerca e ha la possibilità
di rimanere a vivere in questi paesi,
lavorando e impiantando
la propria azienda,
dovrà sapere
che la maggior parte delle spese
grava su chi investe.
Sempre durante le mie ricerche
sul campo, in giro per l'Italia,
è emerso che nei paesi il welfare sociale
lo portano avanti le donne,
attraverso il lavoro
di cura e di accudimento
dei parenti, dei familiari anziani
e dei figli;
così anche del lavoro domestico.
Perché nei paesi esiste ancora
una forte impronta patriarcale
che costringe le donne
all'accudimento coatto dei più fragili.
Se hai dei figli
sei costretto a licenziarti,
perché nei paesi non esistono
asili, ludoteche
né mezzi di trasporto per accompagnarli,
e anche bambini per farli giocare.
Sempre alle donne spetta il lavoro di cura
durante la convalescenza
dei parenti anziani,
e anche di accompagnarli dal medico.
Se sei una persona anziana,
sicuramente avrai bisogno
di un medico di base:
e questi, in un paese molto piccolo,
potrebbero non esserci,
o addirittura potrebbe
scegliere arbitrariamente
di non recarsi al lavoro,
perché tanto ci abitano pochi abitanti
e sa che i paesani sono ricattabili.
O addirittura, i medici
potrebbero rimanere in macchina,
con il riscaldamento acceso,
e passare la ricetta dal finestrino
mentre fuori, all'esterno,
in un paese d'inverno,
gli anziani fanno la fila.
Nei paesi si muore
perché l'autoambulanza arriva dopo un'ora.
Se sei un adolescente,
sei costretto a viaggiare per studiare.
Sei fortunato se qualcuno ti accompagna
per frequentare i tuoi amici,
per andare alle feste,
per imparare a suonare
uno strumento musicale
o per praticare uno sport:
sennò, sei completamente
tagliato fuori dalla tua vita sociale.
Perché vi racconto queste storie?
Perché oggi, a livello
istituzionale e politico,
per tornare a vivere nei paesi
si parla di coraggio e di intraprendenza:
ma una società equa dovrebbe dare a tutti
le stesse possibilità di partenza,
e non abbiamo bisogno né di coraggio
né di intraprendenza, bensì di diritti.
Manca ancora una categoria di persone,
di cui non vi ho parlato:
sono gli invisibili delle aree interne.
Sono quei ragazzi e ragazze
che dai paesi non se ne possono andare,
e che non possono permettersi
di avere più residenze,
quindi partire e tornare per le vacanze.
Sono quei ragazzi
che per motivi familiari,
economici e anche di istruzione,
non hanno potuto scegliere
e non possono avere una vita migliore.
E su di loro non esistono
né strategie nazionali né programmazione,
e non sono nello sguardo di nessuno.
Ma non possiamo permetterci
di lasciarti soli e di abbandonarli.
Questo abbandono
arriva davvero in profondità.
E fino a quando non saremo in grado
di garantire a tutti e a tutte
i servizi essenziali e i diritti,
allora sarà meglio spopolare i paesi.
Nei prossimi anni,
assisteremo alla scomparsa definitiva
di molti borghi e frazioni.
Sia perché sono popolati
da persone molto anziane,
sia perché non è più dignitoso
vivere e pensare al proprio futuro.
Cosa farei?
Spopolerei i paesi, e pagherei le persone
per andarsene, per essere felici.
Gli darei i soldi per formarsi,
per imparare un mestiere;
e per esplorare, attraverso il desiderio,
e scegliere se rimanere
a vivere in un paese,
in maniera consapevole,
o andarsene.
Gli darei soldi per viaggiare,
per imparare le lingue
e per esplorare le proprie passioni.
Perché chi non ha strumenti
per leggere il cambiamento,
il cambiamento è destinato a subirlo.
(Applausi)